pour avancer le monde a besoin
spécialiste mais aussi d'explorateurs
moi ce soir je vais vous parler
d'exploration je m'appelle louis je suis
le co fondateur de nioko néo causé une
marque de prêt-à-porter éco-responsable
et croyez moi dans une industrie qui est
considérée comme la seconde la plus
polluantes au monde
faire des vêtements éco responsable
c'est un défi en soi
je pense que si j'avais eu un parcours
plus classique gens n'auraient pas été
capables
en fait c'est la variété des expériences
qui permet de développer le goût pour
l'aventuré et la faculté d'adaptation
moi je viens de montmartre un quartier à
paris à montmartre tout le monde est
différent tout le monde vient de quelque
part il ya des gens du showbiz il ya des
commerçants il ya des immigrés il ya des
il ya des truands
il ya que des minorités où il n'ya pas
de minorités au choix le résultat c'est
que tout le monde vit très bien ensemble
et moi j'ai adoré cette ambiance heures
mais un jour au collège comme j'étais
bien dans ma classe mes professeurs ont
convaincu ma mère de m'inscrire dans une
école privée
apparemment pour mon bien moi j'étais
pas convaincu en fait je comprenais pas
pourquoi je devais quitter ce fabuleux
brassage multiculturel pour me fondre
dans un milieu qui me paraissait
totalement homogène
alors après le premier jour d'école
je suis rentré à la maison je me suis
enfermée à double tour dans la salle
demain et j'ai démarré une grève de la
faim
vous imaginez la tête de ma mère j'exige
j'ai ma réintégration immédiate dans mon
collège du xviiie arrondissement j'ai
dit à ma mère je veux être avec des gens
qui viennent de partout parce que plus
tard je serai toujours à l'aise avec
tout le monde pas mal non
en tout cas apparemment ça a fonctionné
parce que après quelques heures de
négociations de discussion juste à temps
pour le dîner elle avait accepté
c'était ma première rébellion j'avais
12-13 ans malheureusement pour ma mère
pardon maman est allée en avoir d'autres
au lycée j'ai commencé à sécher les
cours
j'organisais des soirées dans un cabaret
avec des potes
entre les soirées on organisait des
nuits poker avec les commerçants et les
petits voyous du coin c'était un peu
comme dans un film
et puis à force ce qui devait arriver
arriva trop de nuits blanches
j'ai fini par me faire expulser du lycée
en terminale
après tout j'étais le délégué de la
classe et quand même montré l'exemple
pas inspiré mes camarades
bon je m'en suis sortie je m'en suis
remis j'ai quand même passé mon bac j'ai
fait trois jours de droit à assas
suffisamment long pour moi et je suis
parti à new york dans le plus grand
melting-pot du monde faire une école de
cinéma
j'allais enfin pouvoir faire mes propres
films créer mes personnages mettre un
peu de poésie dans ce monde de brutes le
problème c'est que new york c'est cher
et en parallèle de ça il a fallu que je
trouve un moyen de gagner de l'argent et
comme j'avais un visa étudiant je
n'avais pas vraiment le droit de
travailler sur le territoire alors
chasser le naturel
je me suis tourné vers le seul milieu
que je connais c'est un petit peu le
monde de la nuit avant que je m'en rende
compte organiser quatre soirées par
semaine dans tous les clubs les plus
branchés de manhattan
je croise régulièrement dicaprio beyoncé
jay-z busta rhymes
je me suis fait courser par la mafia
albanaise je me suis retrouvé dans
l'es10 l'immobilier de plusieurs
milliers de millions de dollars par don
je n'ai pas touché un kopeck évidemment
mais ça c'est un autre sujet l'important
c'était que après tout ça tout ces
explorations j'étais enfin prêt j'avais
développé une grande faculté
d'adaptation
c'était mon petit diplôme à moi ça
valait pas grand chose en france mais ça
allait beaucoup me servir pour la suite
ça faisait trois ans que j'étais à new
york j'avais 22 23 ans était le moment
des choix
la plupart de mes amis étaient en train
de sortir de l'école supérieure et de
s'engager dans des voies
professionnelles et moi je voulais pas
rentrer dans le rang je voulais m'en
créé dans cette liberté je voulais
construire ma vie autour de ses valeurs
alors je me suis dit qu'il fallait que
je crée une marque parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est une marque c'est une vision du
monde
c'est des valeurs c'est une communauté
qui les partagent avec vous c'est une
liberté de ton une liberté d'action
alors je suis rentré à paris il y avait
quelques amis on s'est lancés ça
s'appelait noise control
ça voulait dire pas de contrôle de la
jeunesse a sonné mieux en anglais notre
devise c'est est que la jeunesse n'avait
pas d'âge
mais on a vite réduit ça à nos locaux
vous avez vu comment j'ai galéré à le
dire c'était trop long et on a rencontré
nos premiers fournisseurs nos premiers
mots des lits sont à dessiner nos
premiers modèles on a appris les codes
et les pratiques de la mode
on s'est mis à travailler avec des
artisans extraordinaire des savoir faire
ancestraux
on a bossé avec des
tisserand italien qui avait été fondée
au xviie siècle des portugais on a
appris ils nous ont transmis cet amour
du travail bien fait de la qualité de
l'exécution
on l'a découvert la tente des premiers
prototypes le frisson quand tu reçois la
production et moi je suis
particulièrement tombé amoureux des
matières mais avec nos petites lunettes
d'idéalistes on s'est quand même rendu
compte qu'il y avait deux trois choses
qui n'allaient pas dans la mode la mode
comme toutes les industries
c'est une industrie de marge et le but
du jeu c'est d'augmenter les volumes et
de baisser les coûts du coup la plupart
des marques n'hésitent pas à se
reproduire
quitte à brader en fin de saison et à
utiliser les matières les moins chers le
problème c'est que c'est les pires mais
écologiquement parlant
le résultat c'est qu'on fait 120
milliards de vêtements par an et que 60%
des fibres utilisées sont des fibres
synthétiques 30% sont du coton ça fait
90 % de matière extrêmement nocives pour
l'environnement
les fibres synthétiques s'est fait à
partir de pétrole
c'est du plastique c'est pas
biodégradables et est ce que les gens
savent pas toujours c'est que quand vous
les mettez dans une machine à laver
elle libère des micro particules
plastiques dans les eaux usées
directement jusque dans les océans
en fait c'est tellement peu anodin que
greenpeace a estimé en 2014 que ça
représentait déjà l'équivalent de 50
milliards de bouteilles plastiques le
coton ces deux ennemis % des surfaces
cultivées dans le monde pour 25 % des
pesticides utilisés
dingue non
pour faire un tee shirt il faut 2500
litres d'eau alors quand on a réalisé
que la création la fabrication d'un
vêtement pouvait être un acte aussi
impactant pour la planète car vêtements
ce n'était pas simplement un médium pour
passer un message des valeurs mais que
ça pouvait être un geste militant
on s'est fixé un nouveau but on allait
devenir la marque la plus écoresponsable
au monde en leur temps
l'oréal avait déclaré la guerre aux
cheveux cassants et aux pointes sèches
nous on allait déclarer la guerre aux
matières qui détruisent l environnement
alors on a banni 95% des matières
utilisées sur le marché et on s'est mis
à utiliser exclusivement celle qui
présentait les caractéristiques
écologiques les plus extraordinaires pas
d'irrigation pas de pesticides que du
bio dégradable on s'est mis à utiliser
des matières ancestrale dont les
filières avec quasiment disparu du
chanvre du lot dessus stu l'un des
matières végétales fait à partir de bois
à partir de kelly pts us on a utilisé
des boutons en noir on a même fait des
boutons en laye vous avez déjà vu des
boutons en laye je vous rassure moi ya
quelques semaines je savais pas que ça
existait non plus maintenant je peux
plus m'en passer
c'était c'était bien c'était génial je
connais aucune marque qui fait ça déjà
mais ce n'était pas assez
on voulait aller plus loin encore on
avait une petite idée qui nous trottait
dans la tête une idée un peu folle on se
disait et si on n'utilisait pas de
matière
ou plutôt et si on ne produisait pas de
matière on avait l'intuition qu'avec 120
milliards de vêtements produits par an
il y avait bien quelques rouleaux qui
s'était perdu en route
du coup on aller sur le terrain on
allait voir les usa on allait voir les
dépôts on a ra fouillé on a remonté le
fil ont comme des chercheurs d'or qui
cherchent un gisement et on a trouvé
on a trouvé des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de matières de saison passée
qui était devenu obsolète des surplus de
production des annulations de designers
qui n'attendaient qu'une chose être
incinérée en enfouis et on s'est dit
mais si on arrive à les utiliser
pas besoin de produire de nouvelles
matières si on produit pas de nouvelles
matières on ne consomme pas de
ressources naturelles
on était sur quelque chose d'intéressant
on était assez limité mais restait une
dernière étape à franchir
je préfère vous le dire tout de suite si
vous essayez de le faire le jour vous
arrivez avec des dizaines et des
dizaines de petits rouleaux de taille de
couleurs de motifs différents
chez une usine on va vous regarder comme
un fou ou pire un amateur et on va vous
montrer la porte en fait d'une manière
générale quand vous essayez de faire
quelque chose de nouveau on vous dira
souvent non on vous parlera la route et
dans ces moments là vous aurez besoin de
deux choses de persévérance voir
d'obstination et d'imagination
en fait il faudra inventer des chemins
de traverse des moyens de contourner les
obstacles qui vous emmène dans la
direction que vous souhaitiez ça sera
plus long ça sera plus dur mais c'est
pas ce qui compte
l'important c'est d'arriver
nous la solution elle se trouvait dans
le système de production pyramidale de
la mode
je vous explique si vous êtes une marque
parisienne puis vous avez une collection
en produire vous allez voir un agent il
vous place dans une usine à l'étranger
et puis si vous êtes sérieux
consciencieux vous aller leur rendre
visite une fois ou deux et vous attendez
tranquillement votre production mais ce
que vous ne savez pas c'est qu'il ya une
chance sur trois pour que votre
collection soit en fait sous traiter à
un ou plusieurs ateliers
pourquoi parce que les usines ont une
hantise celle de voir leur chaîne de
production vide alors elle ratisse large
très large
elles prennent toutes les commandes ou
presque et après on se débrouille qui a
trop de travail c'est une surcharge
au pire on aura du retard ou alors on
externalise où ça dans des petits
ateliers qui n'ont pas pignon sur rue
qui n'ont pas la gens qui ne parlent pas
anglais mais qui font un travail
remarquable tellement remarquable que
personne ne le remarque évidemment
c'était ça la clé fallait qu'on remonte
à la source fallait qu'on casse cette
pyramide
alors on a ouvert un bureau à bucarest
et on a recruté une équipe locale et à
force de road trip dans la région à
force de petites annonces dans le
journal la force d' enquêtes de terrain
on a trouvé cinq dix vingt ateliers qui
a accepté de travailler sans minimum 4
avec qui a accepté de travailler nos
matières et pour la première fois il
allait toucher l'intégralité du fruit de
leur travail
bah oui elle est plus d'intermédiaires
et plus d'agents il ya plus
c'était eux et nous une relation directe
long terme franche grâce à tous ces
efforts
je suis très fier de pouvoir vous dire
que un vêtement ne yo causé en moyenne
88 % de co2 85% de pétrole 40 % d'eau en
moins que le reste de l'industrie
en 2019 s'est déjà 5,6 millions de
litres d'eau économisés grâce à nos
choix
mais ce qui me rend le plus fier c'est
que c'est une équipe européenne avec des
gens qui viennent de partout
c'est un circuit unique respectueux de
l'homme et de l'environnement
c'est douze personnes qui travaillent
dans quatre pays à construire un monde
meilleur
et croyez moi ça n'est que le début
alors si par hasard dans la salle ce
soir il ya des gens qui se sentent
explorateurs en herbe
j'aimerais leur cité un mec qui
s'appelait steve jobs pas si vous
connaissez
il parlait d'un concept que j'aime
beaucoup ça s'appelle connecting de dot
l'idée c'est que c'est à la fin de votre
parcours que vous le comprenez vraiment
c'est à la fin que vous comprenez que
tous les péripéties les succès les
passions vous avez enfants les projets
parallèles tout avait en fait insensé
que vous êtes exactement là où vous
deviez être alors n'ayez pas peur de
l'inconnu si vous avez une cause juste
de la persévérance et de l'imagination
vous arriverez toujours à destination
place
[Applaudissements]